you know I lucked out
honey no you told no I'm not lost me
look you know how you're having a dream
dream you got a pea yeah okay and then
you're like oh my god
there's no bathrooms what I'm gonna do
Oh Saints watching oh wait and in real
life you actually have to pee yes yeah
okay everybody has that right that's the
point I'm trying to make I proposed that
last night I dreamt I get a kid so real
we named him after your eccentric uncle
Oh what was his name Morgan Morgan so
you woke up in naturally we were
expecting yes
now please maybe we don't even have a
wedding date yet you set argost 27th
that's the decoy date because this media
circus that's going on is driving me
crazy okay this is me on edge I'm sorry
because I'm trying to keep all the
pictures out of the paper and off the
internet so your weddings not ruined no
one's working harder than remember that
kid from TMZ that you had me trade paint
with on the FDR Drive well I got a case
against me now that's my fault yeah it's
your fault Lou doesn't a plus I'm half
like the godfathers really funny now you
gotta go to court that's why when you
get out of the car and just distress
Burt I see you Burt Burt you son of a
tell me a break come here man we gotta
get him a girlfriend you know anyone
anyone everybody it's Charlie we got a
whole bunch of infinity war to talk
about probably one of the most important
scenes in the entire movie because of
how it charts the timeline it gives you
a beginning a middle and an end point
for Iron Man's character so we got to
break it down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a new brand of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video the
important thing about this is that it
foreshadows what the end of Iron Man's
arc is going to be because I think
everybody is really sad that things are
ending it's gonna be this bookend for
all these phase 1 Avengers even though
some will continue into phase 4 not
everybody is gonna die but in contrast
to the really downer infinity war ending
leaving all the heroes broken we could
talk all day about that it sounds like
Avengers for the tone is gonna be wildly
different and I think it will have a
much more hope
ending that will get you really excited
about what's going to be happening next
like there will be a couple people that
definitely stay dead and it'll be a huge
bummer but for the most part things will
end in a very positive way Josh Brolin
has been going on and on about how he's
been thinking about these two Avengers
films as this grand Shakespeare play
most of Shakespeare's comedies end in
weddings which is why I think it's so
important that this scene happens at the
beginning and obviously a lot of these
films have been framed around Iron Man's
character he's been the base of the
pyramid the backbone that they've built
the last 10 years of Marvel on so his
arc is one of the more important ones
for foreshadowing how things are going
to end so what do they say during this
that they did not say during the scene
that made it into the movie
Tony mistakenly thinks that they've
scheduled their wedding for August 22nd
after the movie has aired in theaters it
gets a little bit meta too because it's
sort of like them ending in a real world
way too like after next summer the
Avengers will be moving into the new
phase of their lives and the old phase
one Avengers will be going out to
pasture but within the world of the
movie it was gonna be happening a couple
months after they have this conversation
so think of everything during infinity
war is the prime timeline everything is
left at the end everyone's lost they're
broken but Doctor Strange has this big
plan we all know they're gonna try and
fix everything during Avengers 4
possibly resetting things and creating a
new timeline just remember that we'll
come back to that
so Pepper is saying that no no that's
the decoy date to mislead the paparazzi
also a bit of a meta term for the fans
like trying to figure out the plot of
Avengers 4 no we're throwing out decoy
information to throw people off
Tony responds by saying they need to get
married before that peppers like no no
we need to get married after that date
and then happy is like just elope just
go do it go do it right now
remember in the actual version of the
scene that we saw in theaters she says
you should have shirts in your closet
not suits of armor
so he's metaphorically hanging up his
arc reactor thinking about having a
child with her becoming more domestic
passing off the day-to-day of saving the
world to the new guys like spider-man
and Black Panther so you think about
this they're very openly foreshadowing
how they're going to end the movie
probably on the wedding of Tony in
Pepper like in the way that they
foreshadow those people coming back and
the way the soulstone works how it
preserves life after death because they
turn all these people to ash but Black
Panther and spider-man among
are definitely getting sequels
spider-man gonna be happening right
after Avengers for next year so they're
very open about the way they foreshadow
plot twists which is what they're doing
in this conversation here is their
foreshadowing the end of Iron Man's arc
specifically but because his arc is so
important to the entirety of all this it
also serves as the big celebratory event
in the reason for them all to be
on-screen together like Sebastian Stan
says that he had a scene with every
Marvel character ever on screen at the
same time you would do that at a wedding
so you know people expecting a doubt or
ending like what if they're at a funeral
like Captain America's funeral that
would be another reason for all the
characters to be on-screen together
but remember infinity war was the downer
ending Avengers 4 will probably be a
much more hopeful ending but here's the
thing in the prime timeline remember
we're still at the end of infinity war
right now the Russos revealed that Iron
Man was permanently damaged emotionally
by spider-man's death and physically
from his battle with Thanos and unable
to move forward given the fact that his
whole thing is that he's the Futurist
who builds himself new armor upgrades on
the fly every year and in Avengers 4 in
this promo art he's wearing the exact
same suit of armor and this looks like
is happening towards the end of the film
because Captain Marvel's teamed up with
them like this is their final battle
with Thanos is implied that there's a
big time jump so if he's wearing the
same suit of armor that means that he's
probably stuck in a rut meaning that
when he came back to Planet Earth it was
a little bit like after the first
Avengers film remember how crazy he went
they didn't deal with it till Iron Man 3
so safe to say that after he came back
he and pepper probably never went
through with the wedding things move
forward but the whole idea things are
more hopeful in Avengers they learn to
be true heroes they fixed the universe
and reality there's also some implied a
time-travel because using spider-man as
a benchmark spider-man's movies moved
one year at a time we know Scott Lang is
going to be time traveling a little bit
because of the time vortices inside the
quantum realm implying that there's at
least a couple years between the end of
infinity war in the beginning of
Avengers 4 so they fix everything by the
end of Avengers 4 it implies that
they're creating an alternate timeline
or an alternate reality where things
turn out really awesome for them because
they made all the right moves and they
fixed everything so beginning to end
infinity war in a
vengers for only actually take place
over the course of a couple weeks even
though like all the Avengers that fix
everything will probably remember
everything that happened like Iron Man
will probably remember all the things
that happened after he saw spider-man
die spider-man will remember dying
Doctor Strange will remember everything
they'll have lived several years even
though as we view it from beginning to
end in Avengers for only a couple of
weeks we'll have gone by they can have
their wedding that will satisfy Iron
Man's request to move the wedding up
great we need to do it now we need to do
it quickly and it will also satisfy
peppers comment we needed to do it after
the date because even though she might
not recognize that all that time has
passed
Iron Man we'll know it'll would have
been several years inside his head so
everything is just pointing towards them
being relatively honest when they're
foreshadowing this potential wedding
because remember how they set that up
during spider-man homecoming what am I
going to tell you something how about
how you still got that ring to it I
think eight are you kidding
I mean carrying this since 2008 like I
just thought that it was meant to be
this funny joke but no no no turns out
they mean to pay that off it goes all
the way back to the Iron Man films like
he was getting ready to propose
got a little sidetracked with all the
stuff he was doing with the Avengers but
finally he's paying that off it just
feels like the Russos mean to pay off
this wedding and that would be like the
big event to end it on but let me know
in the comments how do you think they'd
end Avengers 4 that makes you happy
about what happened and excited for
what's coming up next what will happen
is is there's a whole bunch of other
stuff to get through the Deadpool
blu-ray is dropping really soon too so
I'm sure there'll be some bonus features
for that I'll do videos whenever it does
leave all your requests in the comments
below where you wait for everything
click here to re-watch that venom
trailer a billion more times and click
here for that other infinity ward's
deleted scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]